congratulations stacy that'll be a good
way to kick off the weekend
all right everyone it is friday morning
and time for what's trending with
las vegas now host mercedes martinez she
is live as you can see from the mixed
941 studios this morning mercedes good
morning to you happy friday
good morning john alex so good to see
you guys we are starting with two
huge music releases that happened
overnight
bts released their new single butter
check it out
the music video premiered on youtube
about
nine hours ago and it's already been
viewed
more than 54 million
times butter is being called the dance
anthem
of the summer it is so good also
olivia rodriguez first album sour was
released last night
there are eight songs on it including
driver's license
gotta love that song heartbreak oh
i can't handle it also next up prince
william is trending because
fans are losing it over his
buff arms he shared this picture
of himself getting the first dose of the
coveted vaccine
and people were really struck by those
biceps
it's no surprise though he plays soccer
and polo and he has a home gym but
we just didn't realize what was under
all those suits that he
wears john alex mercedes i don't think
alex is convinced about the
quote-unquote
guns of the prince i i was telling john
mercedes they obviously don't have ryan
reeves to get to watch every
so often so that's what they get i mean
that's not apples to apples it's not
well uh you know unlike uh prince uh the
prince there
ryan reeves may have put a spell on you
like for example alex the sanderson
sisters who have just figured out who
they are
yes for real and that's okay john you
have time because
finally mercedes we have details on
hocus pocus too
yes a simple is finally in the works
after fans
begged for years to see something like
that
uh everybody's so excited sarah jessica
parker bette midler and kathy and jimmy
all posted about it yesterday
they are all going to reprise their
roles in hocus pocus 2.
filming starts soon it's going to debut
on disney plus
in the fall of next year hocus pocus has
been a halloween staple ever since the
movie came out
in 1993.
i mean i've seen it dozens of times alex
i know you haven't seen it before
mercedes john's never seen hocus pocus
i don't even know if that's surprising
to you i know
i've never seen it either what oh my
gosh high five mercedes high five
high five it is so good i watch it
several times i i started
to watch it one time and i fell asleep
but it was just a bad day it had nothing
to do with the movie
okay it did put a spell on you it really
did
okay we're gonna watch the first one and
then we'll get you guys to the second
one this fall okay
yeah we can't watch the sequel mercedes
first one first
okay thanks mercedes oh man all right
weekend
have a good morning show have a good
weekend